ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are here with uh comedian
krista stefano from new york
city thank you for coming we appreciate
you've never done the show ever have you
ah
i've never i'll tell you what i've never
done it in this studio are you nervous
about this
l.a no just being on the show
you know here's the deal we're the new
rogan
i don't want to i don't want to start a
fight with him right but i literally
will yeah we are the new joe rogan
experience
what happens in that chair
can destroy your life or it can save it
yeah the only difference between this
studio and joe rogan studios joe rogan
has beef jerky made out of native
americans in the waiting room yes he
does he does like barrels of whiskey
yeah and uh and armed security and navy
seals
that are armed security but i'll tell
you right now ben's got great hand eye
he does so if you start a problem he's a
real lanky guy but he's got good hand
eye and he he can get down on the ground
with you he's a grappler ben is ben a
grappler i don't know probably not he's
one of those guys i wouldn't i wouldn't
[ __ ] with ben at all well because he has
that wasp cold texas thing so you can
just walk away he doesn't know what
emotions are so he doesn't feel which is
what's so good and that's why he does
good at the job if you did if you did
ben's face on that face app face swap
thing he would seamlessly fit into most
mass shooters profiles 100 facially 100
yeah yeah he's got that face the only
reason ben doesn't shoot up a school is
because he doesn't like traffic
right like he come you know what i mean
like he'll be like oh my god it's
[ __ ] nine o'clock there's still
traffic but i'll tell you what with all
the over saturation that's going on in
comedy and entertainment in general the
last stand of going viral might be a
mass shooting there well what a what a
great way to get banned from every
platform at once see this is guerrilla
warfare now they come on
the podcasters come on they try to get
you banned immediately that's what we
should all do we should all just go on
each other's shows and try to get banned
like try to get their
like i should just go on uh taste buds
with uh sal and derosa yeah uh great
show and what i should do is when
they're arguing about peanut butter and
jelly i should go do you think black
people have different skull shapes than
white people
until they're taken off youtube that's
the only way we can win now is get each
other kicked off honestly it's i would
like to go back i was telling ben before
he got here like go back to like opie
and anthony vibes yes you know what i
mean do things like that yeah because i
think that's what real comedy is yeah we
got to try to get got to try to get each
other banned yeah to try to get
everybody banned and you know we'll see
what happens for me
i feel
i feel safe
that no matter what happens because i'm
surrounded by transgender and puerto
ricans you were very smart to build to
put yourself on an island full of brown
people yep who have mutilated their
bodies yep that is such a benefit for
you what's been beautiful about my life
the last month is my father yes uh who
we call tampa tony is up from florida
yeah he's been staying with me for a
month and it was the first time he's
ever been around tt jerry who's a
transgender puerto rican person nanny
nanny
yeah she's my show tt jerry is my uh
kid's mom's godfather yes did prison
time for 20 years transitioned in prison
and is now my youngest daughter's
godmother right same person right so
it's very fun to see to tell my irish
catholic conservative bringing her up
right now here she is
yeah she looks like john cicada with
aids yeah um so and she does have aids
and there's nothing wrong with that hey
whatever it is it is right yeah and she
it's in remission yeah and sometimes it
flares up i'll tell you what she doesn't
have covered right
um so so what's been interesting what's
been nice is watching my father because
you watch the news long enough you get
brainwashed a little bit to think that
you know a a transgender
latino inmate wouldn't get along with a
conservative fat guy from the bronx
right who now lives in florida and they
you could you you couldn't be more wrong
about the reality of the situation which
is that they are best friends yes they l
the other night they're watching
fox news right like my father has fox
news on all day every day it's what it
is it's what you expect 75 year old guy
from florida so uh tucker carlson is on
at night and tt jerry's watching doesn't
know anything about you know the news
doesn't watch it at all
she you know she watches wendy williams
and stuff to get the news and she tucker
carlson is on and out of nowhere uh tt
says
uh to my father she goes you know for a
white guy tucker carlson looks like he
probably got a big dick
and my father was like you know i never
thought about that jerry and they had
like this moment yeah where it was like
they then started
talking about you know both watching
fox news because tt was you know thought
thinks tucker carlson is legitimately
hot and hasn't stopped talking about how
she wants tucker carlson's dick and my
father loves his politics but they came
together yeah and they dropped my kids
off at school at summer camp every day
so i think the people at the summer camp
are like what is this old man with
diabetes and fake knees
walking around this transgender puerto
rican woman saying she wants to suck
talker carlson's [ __ ] for dropping off
these two little girls right and it's
what my life is and it is the new sitcom
yeah it is a new sitcom that no one will
make sadly yes well no one's gonna make
well we don't know
if anything i'll put it on youtube yes
that's what i'll do you should i would
it's a new modern family it's a new um
it's it's it's kind of like the new uh
everybody loves raymond but with the
transgender you are getting to something
that i think is legitimate and that is
that
people when you go online everybody
hates everybody right when you actually
put people in a room together oh my god
it's actually not the case
no yeah no no i don't well we see that
comedy shows no but everybody's fine
everything is fine everybody's fine i
know there's issues there's issues
there's issues but that's why i moved to
staten island because now i'm on an
island of yeah you want to complain
about an issue yeah it better be the
right issue that's right because if
you're complaining about another type of
issue you're going to be asked to leave
that island you know what i think what
i've learned is that
when people
are
really concerned with politics a lot of
the time it masks the fact that they
themselves
are bored sure it's boredom yeah it's
real boredom and to which i present to
them many many options including drugs
yeah it is to i was a drug addict for
many many years it is a better life
it is more interesting you are more
focused uh i i mean taking a nice drive
to go get oxycontin in suffolk county
long island you know
to me is a better way use of your time
than arguing over facebook about health
care yeah and not enough people
are out there not enough people are
talking about actually saving white
people right we have to save the whites
i was just in providence rhode island
and they're and they're all dying all
these white people are dying of heroin
overdoses they have blue lips and
they're sunken in eyes and they follow
you around in a drug store and it's
uncomfortable i was in a dunkin donuts
in providence i was just just there last
weekend i was in a dunkin donuts in
providence i mean full meth crackheads i
bought a donut a you know a powdered
sugar i i blew i went in the parking lot
because just in case there was a little
fentanyl residue on it i was like i'm
not sure no it's it's so bad right now
yeah and louis c.k can't put everyone in
a movie you know and also not everyone
can get louie on the podcast right so
that's the whole well he's doing all of
them if that's what i'm saying he's
doing everybody he's gonna do ours in
august that's amazing we're not talking
about the movie
we got a big show here we can't just
spend an hour talking about the movie we
can't spend an hour talking about it
we'll tell people to go see it but
there's other questions we must ask ask
now um i i wanted to do this because
it's very interesting they just you know
you you do some acting not a ton not a
ton i am doing a volkswagen commercial
tomorrow because germany's fighting back
yes and now they've hired you which i
love yeah i love that volkswagen goes
you know what
yeah forget about diversity inclusion
let's go with the most german looking
head we can find what is the commercial
do you know yet it's literally just
going out there i'm i'm trying to now
sell the volkswagen atlas um which is
the truck which is a truck which is a
beautiful truck which actually is good
for me with the family i have what you
should have negotiated you they should
have given you a volkswagen atlas well
so we're still but that see the thing
times are tough right now right that's
the thing is i literally was like i have
why did i have taken uber
to the you know from the airport why was
i not picked up in a volkswagen or give
me a volkswagen right like we genuinely
don't have the money to give you a
volkswagen you just pay to do the
commerce yeah and that's it so you go in
there and do you know what the script is
yet do you know what you have to do it's
kind of something it's about like the
rules of the road kind of thing like
volkswagen's
yeah i like a company yeah implicated in
one of the greatest is did did
volkswagen get involved i know mercedes
was but was volkswagen involved i
believe volkswagen wasn't but i like
that they're still focused on order yeah
there's something nice about okay so the
rules of the road
well so what happened was it's too much
the way i even got this gig is the head
it'll come out weeks after you're paid
yeah so yeah
well
the only reason i'm talking so fluidly
is because the money's already in the
bank oh great and you won't get it back
that's great so no matter what i'll move
to another country so so i i'll move to
germany where i'm free so
so i'll uh uh they said that the head of
volkswagen um or whoever the digital ad
people whatever were looking for a
german comic and they couldn't find the
german comics so my name got picture
like his last name is the stefano but
then the head of volkswagen took a look
at me was like there's no way that guy's
not fully german right and
so that's so so i like a company too
that although they're in about
inclusiveness they include everybody and
all this and that and you know they just
are like who's the people are going to
buy the car let's get a guy who looks
like the people who buy the car i've
never kind of like that and i'm i'm this
is anecdotal i've never seen
a non-white person in a volkswagen no
ever in my life no which is fine it's
fine
it's fine it's called the demographic
it's fine i'm not gonna be the
spokesperson for lincoln navigators
right you know right it's a great point
so and that's fine right that's fine i
don't know why there's such an issue
about these things like for example
sometimes you just have to be strong
with people so last week i wasn't home
they had to fix the air conditioner uh
units in my in my house and one of the
guys went up there guatemalan guy went
up there and i fell through my attic
ceiling right fell on the floor whole
thing blah blah blah blah blah so then
all of a sudden the foreman calls me he
goes yeah my guys his neck hurts now all
of a sudden his neck is hurting trying
to look for some cash so tt jerry being
a career criminal goes up to that room
and says oh you know your neck cards and
the guy says cec and he goes uh he goes
well do you have your papers i just want
to know if you have your papers
and then and then so and then the guy
was like no paper no paper and he goes
yeah he goes through them go back up on
the ladder right and fix the ceiling
[ __ ] yeah so you would think that
and i i wasn't there this was all told
second hand to me of course but but i
but i believe that it happened that way
and that ceiling was fixed and
everything was fine and then there was a
crew of people that came into the house
after that to do some patch up uh some
some of the other air conditioning stuff
and then a ring went missing somebody
stole a ring oh so they were gonna come
you know we had it was a big thing and
tt jerry just flat out said if i don't
get if i don't get that ring back
because it was all the same proof i
don't get that ring back i'm gonna go to
immigration and i'm gonna make sure this
guy gets deported and then guess what
about an hour later the ring was left on
a paint can outside the house so
sometimes this is the pilot of the
sitcom yeah i want you to go in you're
in la right now i want you to go in
and i want you to pitch this hulu
netflix
amazon prime uh hbo max i want you to go
and so this is the resolution of the
pilot yeah my puerto rican transgender
somewhat republican
uh uncle ant
uh goes and threatens to inform on the
paperless undocumented worker and gets
the ring back yeah end of episode one
yeah who's in yeah well how about and it
was it was it was fireworks but this is
the way real life is the story in real
life stop making fire island you gotta
make which by the way it's god bless
everyone but the movie is about gay guys
who go to an island to [ __ ] for a week
and somehow have a bad time yeah somehow
it's bad no they're going to an island
to take molly and [ __ ] this new thing on
hulu but somehow they're everyone's so
racist they can't have fun
the mali and the hormones don't overcome
the racism nobody
in the world right nobody in the world
right has more fun than gay men and
black women yes these are the two groups
that's right far and away because the
most fun when they go
they've been through [ __ ] and they
realize that you have to have fun yes
right so to me it's just funny the idea
of making a film about going to a [ __ ]
paradise right which is what fire island
is right and why are you looking up fire
fest he's so dumb
he's so dumb he's looking up fire fast
right now we're talking about a movie
called firearm yeah he's looking up
firefighters yeah do you realize what i
deal with do you understand right how
how hard it is for me and how impressive
it is i've gotten anywhere with this
with this dead weight [ __ ] yeah
carrie just dead weight right
but my father watched it he thought it
was not so rich asians yeah
yeah that's what he thought it was
he was like yeah
he was telling me
yeah uh but it's it's just funny to me
there's no more and nobody wants to have
fun anymore no no films are about having
fun everything's about educating people
teaching them lessons it's like
you're going to an island where
everyone's going to [ __ ] and they go
well maybe some of them are racist who
cares yeah suck each other off yeah what
no you're right you that's bothering you
yeah it's literally my child who's a
seven-year-old we watched look who's
talking ever seen the movie look who's
talking of course in the first five
minutes of look who's talking in 1989
with john travolta kirsty alley first
five minutes somebody blows up they blow
a load into the into the uterus and then
they got the embryo falling down and the
sperm just gets in the egg and right
away it's [ __ ] it's jizz and in the first
first five minutes they have babies
taught you know the little babies in the
you know right who are born um and and
uh they have an indian baby and they
just give the baby who's you know
talking in a in a voiceover in indian
accent like they did yeah i want to be
reincarnated my daughter's on the floor
laughing her ass hilarious i'm like but
meanwhile then they went woke on one of
the last pixar's and my kid [ __ ]
hated it right it's like just say what's
funny please right the kids don't give a
[ __ ] right you know just be goofy and
silly just be goofy and silly we know
it's not that big of a deal the last
pixar was woke is this where buzz
lightyear yes that's the one yes
but no no no uh is it where he he gets
the salad tossed
no that because there's one where buzz
lightyear gets a salad toss but
lightning
buzz lightyear looks like me get a buzz
lightyear from the new piggy he
literally looks like me to a point where
my conspiracy is that they
literally i mean look
i mean that's insane there it is that's
insane there's buzz lightyear with a
chin full of colors and i think he's is
he gay
in the movie buzz lightyear is gay he's
gay he's gay in the movie we haven't
seen that one yet there was another one
though where they had some woke
messaging which it's whatever
i um i don't know but yeah i mean listen
i don't care whatever i don't i don't
give a [ __ ] about my kids seeing right
gay trent whatever you want to do just
make it funny make it fun i don't care i
don't care because because the bottom
line is the way i view it is my children
are going to get the education in school
and then they're going to get the
education at home right so whatever you
put out there it's my job as the kids
parents my whole thing has always been
leave kids alone let them discover who
they are and what they
uh value in life i think kids are over
parented oh my god yeah and i think that
you know teachers in school their job is
to give kids the fundamental basics
reading writing a rhythm that's right i
don't want you to talk to them about
anything else i don't i don't think they
should because the reality of the
situation is
teachers you know and i mean again i'm
gonna i'm gonna get some flack for this
but
you know it hasn't been going well with
just the reading and the math and the
science not in this country right so
let's focus on that and not so much
trying to build these kids in every area
of their lives i'm very big listen i was
left alone a lot and sure you could say
oh you're doing coke at 13 and blah blah
blah sure you're having fun but i have a
bentley now so here's the point there
you go the reality is and people go oh
that doesn't matter yes it does it does
it absolutely does yeah
um
and it's 2018 it's certified pre-owned
there are problems
and i you know what i mean and i i
understand that because but the reality
is i was left alone and to figure it out
nobody came to me and said you can be a
girl
you know what i mean nobody came to me
and said you can suck a dick you find
out that you can suck a dick through
trial and error yeah you find out and
it's not something that has to be like
nobody has to sit you down and explain
to you
who you want to [ __ ] right you know yeah
that's figure it out i know i think i
think we get so worried about the youth
in this country and like you said we'll
figure it out the thing i think like the
the school my daughter goes to now which
i like again being on staten island
right they don't lean into any of this
stuff my daughter in a couple of months
ago you know they have field trips to
the to capital riot 100 different yeah
she came home with a coloring worksheet
a couple of months ago with you know
they're teaching them about men and
women right and life and careers she
came up with the coloring worksheet it
was coloring you know different people
and what their jobs were the woman had a
broom and was cleaning a stove top and
the man had a hammer to a wall
that's what it was thank you yep
yeah that's what it is now it's
confusing for my daughter because she's
like tt jerry what which one is that
right i'm like that's
yeah that's the one behind this dumpster
sucking [ __ ] for crack have you heard
about the legendary underwear brand
that's totally taken over the podcasting
world famous for their buttery soft
undies and bralettes myunders loves me
undies loves podcasts just as much as
you do it's like you're made for each
other get to know the underwear brand on
every podcaster's lips there's so much
more than me undies uh everybody loves
them i wear them ben wears them
everybody i know wears me undies
everyone knows me undies for their super
soft on these and all this other stuff
we're talking super stretchy
durable cushy socks loungewear
silky softness to your everyday routine
they even make hoodies for your dog oh
wow so you can match shut up so you can
match every important person in your
life available in sizes extra small to
4xl and tons of colors and prints make
myunders your destination for all things
soft and sustainable meundies has a
great offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 20 off
plus free shipping and returns that's 20
off plus free shipping returns 20 off
your first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com that's meundies.com tim
everybody struggles with all kinds of
things but better help is a great way to
get online therapy
okay you can start communicating with
the counselor in under 48 hours
it offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
our listeners get 10 percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com timd
that's
tim
betterhlp.comtimd
i love it
better help what i mean what do you
think about it uh so can i talk about my
personal experience here a little bit
you know i don't think it's appropriate
well i'm not gonna disclose what i
talked about in therapy but i signed up
for better betterhelp i find it to be a
huge stress reliever and i was always
nervous about going into a place to to
talk with a person uh in in real irl you
know and i like it more over the
computer it's much easier
and um yeah i really i support this and
they matched me in under 48 hours did
you know that the therapist that one
happened yeah and i love my therapist
now so
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com there's tim d
that's betterhlp slash tim d it's
important to do
there's a new show on netflix called
heart stopper they have an open call
and this is a very big show it's a lgbtq
or ia2 whatever show
and it's i'm sure it's lovely i have no
beef with the show that of course one of
the people in it they ask him if he's
gay he's not gay and he has to go well i
don't want to tell you because now
everyone will go nuts if they find out
he's straight the kid in the orange kit
connor is probably
most likely straight maybe maybe there's
a little but i mean the reality is but
they have an open call there's an open
call for a cast member who is a uh
uh 16 year old and again one thing that
i think about people like me and you is
that we haven't been given a shot to act
in uh the way that uh many people in our
industry have right and so it says
heartstopper announces casting call for
exciting new role for season two with
lgbtq plus actors encouraged to apply
sorry chris that means me yeah and
here's the role okay
the role right here because i think it
is actually perfect for me
is going to be can you go up ben
thanks ben it's please go up more
i mean here's what's amazing here's what
these podcast producers don't realize
they've all won a lottery right so let's
be very honest they've all really won a
lottery yep they've won a lottery yeah i
don't care what they tell the other
people in their lives yeah they've all
gone to the casino and just they've won
a lottery yeah and and and that's real
and that's why everyone online hates
them right like all the comments like
ben should die because everybody else
wants to be in the lot they want to win
the lineup they want to win they're like
they go i can i scroll up i can scroll
but i don't know if they could see the
thing is maybe some of them couldn't
some of them probably some of them
couldn't and also some of them some of
them the thing what i think was the x
factor with ben is you have trust
because
because he's not that good at this but
he's decent i trust him a lot because
here's what will happen but he's he's
not quick like jamie vernon's very quick
right but he's not really quite some of
these other but he doesn't look like
homeless pimp either which is good which
is the homeless pimp you have to leave
outside of a hotel lobby yeah well not
anymore
now oh he's getting better losing weight
he looks good now he's doing well let's
relax with good but it's on the way yeah
it's in a positive positive way he um
but yeah see ben is trustworthy because
some of these other podcasts uses they'd
unlock that back door yes they'd unlock
that back
for sure yep that's what it is for sure
heart stopper season two open call now i
love this because i feel like i could
actually breathe life into this role
casting for the role of sahar zaheed
there you go sahar zaheed actor must be
a minimum age of 16
uh playing age 16. ben i don't want to
put you under too much pressure could
you find like sides or and that's the
industry terminology for some type of
script or
what because i'm literally not on the
show we are going to film an audition
for zahar
hadid
a 16 year old in the netflix show heart
stopper and look see look i kind of look
like zahara hadid you don't go go look i
want now you focus in on zahara deed
there you go
not too far off that's actually kind of
perfect you get a pair of ben's golf
pants yes an old sweater a wig one of
the you know so what get get maurice's
wig by the way i love that this is an
open call this
would be like several years ago this
would be the photo in a health book of a
person that needed to really like work
out yeah this would be a before picture
before picture they go for example as
you can see
molly has been eating too much
she needs to stop eating but so now ben
what do they want here from uh zahar
uh sahar zhang
we're looking for a plus-sized actor of
british south asian
heritage who identifies as female or
non-binary now by the way let's all just
for fun imagine that coming across the
desk of an executive like lions gate
in 1992
1992 it comes across miramax it's harvey
weinstein's desk and they go we want a
plus-size actor of british south asian
heritage who identifies as female or
non-binary and harvey wants he goes the
hell we do yeah so okay i'm by the way
professional experience is not essential
let's talk for a minute about the
direction that this shitty business
we've gone in has chosen because this is
actually kind of stunning yes it's kind
of stunning right this is a hit show
on netflix right it's one of their
biggest shows they go we are looking for
a fatty bombati
from
british uh from whose british south
asian heritage
who identifies as female or non-binary
professional experience is not essential
meaning you don't have to be an actor or
an actress to be on our hit show to be
on our hit show you just have to be
non-binary or
a fatty boom battery that's all you got
to do and i i mean it starts sahara is
in year 11 at higgs no-nonsense
independent a little cynical at times
that well sure i'd be cynical too
because i'm not an actor or actress yeah
and yet i'm on this show yeah
now listen i'm not i'm gonna say
something here that's gonna get me in
trouble but the person who answers this
call if they're not an actor or actress
should be raped because the reality is
what are you there for like i would be
like you're going to molest my kid if i
was the parent they go they don't have
to be an actor actress just send them on
in
if you feel you're right for this role
we'd love to hear from you via email
only please send a recent photo a little
bit about yourself and contact details
ben got a photo of me recently no we're
sending this right now we're sending
this right now i've had enough let's
make an email i'm sick of being limited
yeah and it said that daniel edwards
casting is committed to yes
what are they committed to thank god
wait hold on read this chris please
daniel edwards casting is committed to
equal opportunities for all performers
regardless of gender race disability
religion or sexual orientation except on
the first page they said you have to be
yes fat indian from [ __ ] britain
right so that's what so what are you
talking about daniel edwards yeah daniel
edwards is a big fat liar liar and but
here's the deal i love gulab jamun which
is an indian little uh donut that spits
uh it spits like uh syrup okay um
because have you ever had gulab jamun i
i thought that was the new d.a of new
york
my point is that who's to say what is
and isn't right
you know i identify as non-binary
because because some days i feel like a
little bit of [ __ ] sure and sometimes i
feel like a dude so i am none but i'm
coming out now i'm kind of coming and
i've said this before right being gay
isn't enough so i'm non-binary now which
means gay plus film i'm in movies that's
what i wanted what does actually
non-binary mean you're not you're
genderless you're you're not a man or a
woman you're in the mix you're on the
spectrum like which used to just be
called a human being who has different
gender feelings all the time like we all
do right sometimes you feel more
masculine sometimes you feel more
feminine right this also doesn't make
any sense because the people that
usually say it also go gender is not
real at all sure so what is this binary
of this thing that doesn't i don't know
well it gets tough because i had i had a
very very person you know non-binary one
of my kid's mom's family members very
woke right all that you know talking i
had a big pool party a couple of weeks
ago yes right on the heels of the roe v
wade stuff i know that's just
controversial but what i will say it's
in the pool we had tt jerry who's
transgender you know on on a rubber
ducky float saying screaming that life
begins at conception right
and then and then this person said the
woke said said you can't say anything
about it you can't say anything about it
you were you're a man and she goes no no
no tj said i'm a woman i identify as a
woman so you said it right because i'm a
woman i can speak on these you know what
kurt metzger calls that
an intersectional car crash yes that's
what kurt metzger calls what it is an
intersectional car crash here we go this
is a photo of me
and it's just too open call at daniel
what's right here let me just say this
comes across my desk i'm not and me if
you said if you said
you know if i was daniel edwards casting
which is committed to racial equality i
would say this isn't necessarily not
a south asian
woman yes you have a south asian glow a
huge
glow and a hue you could be this could
be you know where that's from that's
from remember the show at arlene's
grocery oh of course new york city
that's a photo i believe it might be a
mindy tucker oh she's the best mindy
tucker
yeah somebody during the riot somebody
threw a molotov cocktail through
arlene's grocery really swear to god
yeah down in that area yeah but it was a
fun little venue it was a fun little it
was rebecca trent
so now here's what i want to craft i
want to craft an email because now get
the thing up then what what do they want
because they've asked for certain things
in the email please send a recent photo
a little bit about yourself and contact
details
um
okay where so listen to this oh dude
that last part is funny too let's go
back to the last part let's read the
whole thing daniel edwards cassidy is
committed to equal opportunities for all
performers regardless of gender race
disability religion or sexual
orientation where gender height race or
appearance has been specified we can
confirm such characteristics are a
genuine requirement for the role so
where we are saying
that you have to be something it's a
genuine requirement for the role but
yeah we're committed to equal
opportunities for all performers yeah
unless which by the way it's hilarious
to me because the second part of it it's
like well of course of course it's like
why don't if danielle was casting just
[ __ ] be honest just say just put a
picture up of pumbaa from the lion king
and say this is what the person means to
look like
okay ben i want you to tell them
about myself okay okay yeah
um
first thing i would say i'm over 18.
mm-hmm
i am overweight
and i'm over not being on your show lol
[Laughter]
i am not
south asian
[ __ ] ben spell asian right
i mean christ almighty with him
i am not south asian but
now keep the period okay but all caps
okay
but
now i gotta kind of prove my bona fides
as a south asian non-binary person right
now okay
now
what is south asian non-binary people
like
what do what does a south asian
non-binary person what would they like
yeah south asian non-binary based in the
uk what would i would say they would
like fire island
they'd like the movie fire island
okay
i'm over 18 and i'm overweight and i'm
over not being going to show lol i'm not
south asian but i love gulab jamun there
you go is this all caps no but south
asian means indian right is that what
we're saying yes and others
i would say but i love
gulab salmon gulab jamun g uh
g-u-u-l-a-b
uh
j-a-m-u-n i love gulab jamun i love
gulab jamun and i also and i love hasan
minaj's homecoming king yes i love
hassan minaj's homecoming king on
netflix on netflix
yes i also
a homecoming king on netflix yes
yep okay but i love glob drama and i
love hassan minaj's homecoming king on
netflix
the
the skills i bring to the role are
being fat
[Laughter]
next sentence
[Laughter]
i
i am
also
very
happy
to work
with a team of people
that really value diversity there you go
for this role
i will need
to put on brown makeup
and i will do so
tastefully
there you go
because of skin problems
can you type any faster
because of skin problems it must be all
natural makeup
we also need to come up with a plan yeah
because we will be accused
of doing quote brownface
yes
however
however
when people realize
that i am quote that [ __ ]
100 that [ __ ] okay
they will forgive us
okay
sincerely
tim dillon
now go two lines down go
tim dillon
is a non-binary
[Laughter]
south asian
woman
[Laughter]
a south asian
male tim dillon is a non-binary male
presenting south asian woman there you
go very good nailed it yeah it's good
who is committed
to fat activism
comma
equality
comma
equity
comma
inclusivity
comma
communism
comma
overthrowing
the patriarchy ben hit return yeah yeah
yeah indent
opponent might look weird
overthrowing
the heteronormative
white
patriarchal
capitalistic
violent
oppressive
eco-terrorists
jews
no don't put that that's a joke that's a
joke now i'm kidding about that yeah
okay tim dillon is a non-binary male
presenting south asian woman who's
committed to fat activism equality
equity inclusivity communism
overthrowing the heteronormative violent
oppressive uh
uh oil just say petro uh say uh uh
it's the violent oppressive petro narco
state
there you go there you go
send
send
send it
what's the subject line here um
i put tim dillon submission but your
lucky day
now i wish they had
uh sides for me but i don't think they
care if i'm actually an actor or actress
you have to be uk based which is it's
all it's interesting hello
um i'm in the uk you know i'm fat and
brown
steve will do it is a supporter of the
tim dillon show and you should support
steve will do it on youtube but steve
will do it
uh youtube he has a lot of fun things
that he does he does new videos every
tuesday on his youtube channel steve
will do it is the breakout star of the
nelk boys prank collective
he uh see if he can get one of these
compilations up where he just drinks you
know he really has done an amazing uh
thing here where he drinks uh quantities
of alcohol that should kill him but they
don't
um
like he's uh here's a chug edition
yeah he's you know this is a uh
he's uh
uh insane
and he's you know he's like this
ultimate frat boy but he does good
things for people like he'll if he sees
like a mexican family he puts him in the
back of a pickup truck and drives him up
the road
there's things he does that really like
you know so he's able to really drink
like this like it's oh that's wild no
the things he does dude i mean it kills
people like
i mean dude it's like making me sick
watching
washing it logan paul's looking at him
like what the [ __ ] is he doing
oh my god i mean this is crazy
yeah dude it's it's crazy it's crazy
it's crazy watching this
it's like really i mean he just got on
this
he became part of this group by doing
[ __ ] like this it's crazy
so anybody talking about that they can't
make money or they don't have a job what
about this
everyone can drink a bottle of vodka
like that or at least try
no but i mean that don't do that
i guess you'll
you'll
you'll die or you'll become a famous
millionaire
i don't know
choice is up to you you want to roll
that dice
he's wild with the chugging dude some of
these are downright uncomfortable
jesus
oh he's that's a bottle of proper 12.
oh wow
i mean it's crazy wow
it's crazy man i i mean it's but he's
kind of he's now doing different things
in this he's not just doing this
he's doing a lot of other things where
he'll find
uh like someone with one leg
and
like design a special obstacle course
for them
you know like he's doing different stuff
you know
but that's crazy to watch that chugging
what is that
like that level of
how do you survive the only guy i know
that's done that is that shoe nice 22
guy on youtube and he would have an
ambulance nearby like medics right there
you're like out of the shot by the way
am i looking at our show oh no that's
just cropped wrong see look in this
monitor up here on the left but i'm out
of the shot well that one's cropped
wrong is too i need it so it was in the
shoe i needed it for monitor i look at
both we're perfectly fine actually it's
amateur hour every day here folks every
hour's amateur hour my father gave me
this tv special to me yeah oh nice it's
the only thing i gave you
steve will do it go visit him on youtube
steve will do it he's got over 4.7
million subscribers get him to five get
him to 10. he deserves it he's still
here
how about boris johnson just stepped
down he stepped down well you know what
he's a fun guy and but he went he had
that party during covet yep and people
got upset he's a little corrupt but i
don't understand if my leader had a
party during covert that makes me vote
for him i know not against him i know
you know i think what was upsetting to
people
is it was maybe you know it's it's
something he can get him on everybody
knows these guys are shady right yeah
you can't get them on anything so you
get them on like this little thing
um
i love that like all the people but he
also tried to get a job for a woman he
had an affair with but again it's fun i
mean what do you i mean what are you
gonna do
isn't that feminism you got to keep her
she's got to keep her mouth shut isn't
that yeah it's like you know i liked it
you know who maybe
these old politicians were the old
politicians were probably way worse but
we didn't know anything about it i like
that yeah i like not knowing i like the
shadiness of it there needs to be some
type of uh
you know
like these politicians i believe
have to have a little fun
of course you've gotta have a little bit
of fun and it should stop short of
putting kids in a barbecue with the
clintons on episodes island yeah but
you got to have a little fun like
he's trying to get a job for a woman
that he had an affair with but she's of
age it was consensual you know what i
mean what we know about politicians this
doesn't even this isn't even in the top
10 [ __ ] up things they do no you no no
jude maxwell uh is uh
in new york she's in jail
can she get visitors
no i don't think you can get visitors
don't you have a lot of friends
in the like cop thing yeah well they're
complaining at that barbecue where tt
jerry was yelling life starts at
conception in a rubber ducky float
the the the with wearing a shirt i swear
to god wearing a t-shirt that said
newport not newport rhode island newport
cigarettes so absolutely beautiful it
was that was her merch so she what she
what hers what her gripe with the
maxwell thing and how she was yelling
about racism tt right is she saying why
why does maxwell get 20 years but r
kelly got 30. she goes that's racist oh
and she goes kelly should it why does
why does kelly get more time than
maxwell here's the reality jizzling
maxwell doesn't even make beautiful
music that's what i said yeah i said
it's not i think what happened with r
kelly was that um he's black
yeah
that's what happened and then no but he
i think he was maybe more directly
involved but maxwell was too they can't
really prove
a lot of what maxwell did because then
it would implicate a lot of other people
that are big deal boldface names so you
think 1 000 i'm sure you guys talk about
this a lot you guys but you think 1 000
bona
celebrities on that list 100 proven but
can't too much money involved they will
never we will never see that list
publicly ever in our lives 100
yeah and i'm talking about
prime ministers presidents
uh big people in our government
billionaires absolutely they're on it a
hundred percent now was that presented
do you think the judge to the jury look
at the people that are just in the orbit
bill gates
bill clinton
look at the people that are in this
orbit right these are
high
ranking
like whether you know ex presidents
people that
are
you know incredibly powerful right so
much money right uh i don't believe we
will ever really know
the full scope
of what was going on we can only imagine
it they have an island
in the south pacific right right so
think about it you have an island
you have a plane that is flying people
to an island
for essentially sex tourism that's what
it is you have one of the largest homes
in manhattan one of the biggest
townhouses maybe the largest per square
foot i don't know but it's one of them
it's up there okay
you are backed by the guy who owns
victoria's secret and the limited
billionaire les wexner who you're
quote managing his money or whatever
you're doing
you are
in business with the woman whose father
was a media mogul in the uk
robert maxwell who
uh died very suspiciously
on a yacht
um
and was believed to be a mossad agent
and there was articles written about him
and you know very seymour hirsch like
very good reporters have written about
the extent to which you know when robert
maxwell died i believe there were like
four heads of israeli intelligence at
his funeral for ex-prime ministers of
israel so you have all of these things
happening you can only imagine the scope
of this how bad it would be
how deep the rabbit hole goes
if everyone was exposed because it was
probably a u.s israel u.s operation
where
politicians were compromised they were
blackmailed there were film doing these
things with underage people
they then
were
forever owned
by the interest that blackmailed them
what would you rather have would you
rather be able to see that epstein's
list or get the role as the fat south
asian oh south asian because i kind of
know the abstinence that's what it is
you could throw a dart and get to the
epstein list yeah i mean it's just not
that hard i mean you could literally i i
could off my dome just start writing
names and get to this now is prince
andrew going to prison
he's not it's just not going to happen i
don't think it's going to go to him i
mean i don't know i would have told you
that i don't i didn't think just elaine
maxwell was going to prison much he's in
and and i still think she might get
killed i i think that they need there
needed to be a sacrificial lamb
because what needed to happen was
chiseling maxwell
uh needed to go down because epstein
epstein needed to die
here's what i think happened
i think they realized that epstein might
have talked
he might have been too much of a risk
she needed to go
just lane maxwell you got to remember i
don't know if epstein had like a family
just lane maxwell has lots of sisters
and family they're an intelligence
family the dad was
she might have more of a code of honor
to whatever you want to whatever human
trafficking honor can there be but you
know but the idea that she has that
omerta kind of mafia i'm gonna keep my
mouth shut thing or she may die too i
don't know but it does seem at this
juncture that epstein was judged this
guy's way too much of a risk he may open
his mouth he might have a psychic
episode right blah blah blah because my
always question with that is how did it
all start to unravel like why who let
the secret out so you think epstein
himself did it
well i think well no epstein was accused
by women of uh you know but why now my
point is like why why did it all fall
down now you know what i mean right well
i think somebody had to do something
well i think you basically had fbi
agents that were like we we
we have a case here we have a strong
case and i think it got to a point where
there was a mountain of evidence where
there you know there could have always
been a mountain of evidence but i think
at a certain point what had happened was
epstein served time he got a sweetheart
deal in 2014 for molesting an underage
girl and then he was basically released
back
uh
and he was still having dinner with
people like chelsea handler and those
people after his conviction right i mean
he was still having dinner and hanging
out with very influential people well
dinner with chelsea handler i believe so
i mean
i could look that up but i believe
that's true that's wild no but i believe
that's true i believe that's true well
it's like my father always said and i
believe that dinner was after and i
think it was like people like katie
carrick i i'm unsure
okay so chelsea handler
uh recalls star-studded weird dinner and
absolutely dumb so when was this though
uh was this after
i did go to dinner jeffrey epstein's
house handler told low i don't know who
jeffrey epstein was it was like 20 i
don't know what it was it was a long
time ago i went with katie clark yeah
okay so i remember this woody allen and
suny previn were there there you go not
a great sign yeah um
so so the deal is that this didn't stop
even after he was convicted
okay
um
these types of things didn't really stop
they might have slowed down or calmed
down um but there were more there were
people working on that case
and and there was more they had victims
people willing to come forward a lot of
times it's victims
that come forward but they they don't
have the corruption sex trafficking has
like exploded now there's signs in
hotels that say if you're a victim of
sex trafficking or trained you're just
training you look at kids with their
parents who are they being trafficked
it's like they're their parents this is
a real thing now this is a prevalent
prevalence that's always been a big
thing i think now with the internet it's
much harder to get away with things if
there was no internet jeffrey epstein is
not probably going to jail but i wonder
if these victims couldn't find each
other you know it just makes me think
sometimes with the internet getting so
big and you can't really every secret
can be exposed somebody's going to press
a button going to want to start this
thing over again you know what i mean
like society gets wiped out somehow
because of all this yeah i gotta have
secrets i think the reality was you you
you basically have
a group of people that have controlled
the planet for centuries literally not
knowing what to do with this
and you can see with a lot of the
censorship they're trying to really like
clamp down on what you can say and and
they're branding a lot of things quote
unquote conspiracy theories right
because you know epstein would have been
called a conspiracy theory but there was
too much evidence and there was too much
out already but by the way they would
have classified that as a conspiracy
theory if they could have so that is why
it's important to be free online and
stuff like that um this has been going
on forever they've been trafficking
children forever the founding fathers
could have been sex traffickers we have
no idea thomas jefferson george
washington
they were slave owners so what's worse
that's a great point
you tell me what's worse that's right
what do you want honey let me let me ask
you something sweetie would you rather
would you rather john adams john
quinciano's be slave owner or sex
traffickers he's one of two he's one of
two which one is it and maybe both
well that's why you get the presidency
my whole thing has always been you know
the internet has been this now it's like
this
it was the wild west for a while and now
people are coming and clamping down and
going hey
we got to introduce some guardrails and
right people have used those words right
i remember you know being in a clubhouse
remember clubhouse and i was on that
[ __ ] nightmare killing it on that god
i was i know i thought it was great yeah
i think you you might have been went the
furthest off to andrew schultz he was
right and he was right andrew schultz is
like yeah the next big app will not be
where the weinstein brothers talk about
like math on it he's not wrong about
right now he was right about a lot he
was right about that yeah and uh the the
other thing was that i was in a
clubhouse room and somebody's like we
got to introduce these guard rails
online and it was this uh you know the
woman who's the bumble the billionaire
who started bumble whitney oh whatever
so this idea
and then of course it's like well that's
nice but what are the guardrails and who
decides them right right so
it is one of those things where i don't
think they ever want a situation like
this to happen again right i don't think
they ever want
uh this type of information to leak
right i don't think they want people
organically to to to figure this stuff
out and however they can control that in
the future they will well i'll tell you
what you you know i think we're living
in this very weird time and i hope i'm
wrong i really pray and hope i'm wrong
but i believe in 10 years
you will look back at the internet and
it'll be almost 100 completely corporate
right and it will it will look a lot
more like
uh television did where it was just all
corporate sponsored
uh and it had the entire it had an
edifice
of you know that it was creative and
some of it was creative but a lot of it
was you know this was big business right
and you can see it now already happening
oh yeah well already on twitter i've
been signed in logged into my twitter in
about two months now i have my girl
benatia tweets everything out tweets out
the dates tweets and and literally
getting off that app it's great it has
you feel better so emotionally
instagram there's a little bit of it but
not like twitter well i did it because i
was spending time on it way too much
time and i'm going i need to be writing
a book are you back on it now though no
no ben just tweets clips
i need to be writing a book writing a
movie i need to be working on things
that i can that are actually meaningful
and valuable i'm not saying it's bad to
have a twitter following it's helped me
it's helped sell tickets i've tweeted
funny things but when you realize when
you look at the sum total of it right
you know how many hours have i spent on
that app and what do i have for it what
am i going to release a book like the
tweets you know like what have you
gotten back from that app
um you know i think i think it helps
certain people and it helped me for a
while but i got to a point where i said
i got to allocate time better yeah and i
got to work on things that can be
something because you know at a point in
our career you know
you got to start looking at the end game
of like well what do i want to do i've
had this great show i want to do this
show for as long as i can do it right i
also want to write a book which i'm
working on i want to make a movie listen
you'd love to make two or three but i'd
love to make really one classic movie
that people like and uh put out a few
comedy specials that people like after
that it's kind of like i mean what else
are we you know yeah i mean you know we
talked about this
we've talked about this before it's like
you know now we're gonna have to have an
amalgamation of things in comedy
specifically and entertainment all of
entertainment right we're gonna have to
have an amalgamation of things if we
want to really get out of this yes
because you know we're not going to get
big money on the comedy specials the
movies all it's all because but like
anything else it's not even about
entertainment just you got to do
something because you love it and the
money always comes second that's what
oprah said
who would be great for the role in that
netflix movie my friend said they saw
her do cocaine once in mississippi in a
church right and i don't know if that's
well thank god she didn't get pregnant
there but that's the whole
and well she's gay
oprah is well with gayle right oh that's
right i mean she's a gay fully named
gayle a man named gayle isn't laying the
pipe well no no no her husband's name is
steadman and you'd think steadfast
pipe oh steadman oh the i thought the
guy's name gail king is oprah's gay
lover very interesting you've never seen
this open gal
gayle king is oprah's gay lover oh
beautiful deadman
is uh her
that's oprah's gay lover
steadman
her husband i believe is her beard
this is again uh bandied about talked
about okay so this is like a lot of
people know about this well people have
said it
oh there's stedman
there you go but they are legally
married
i don't know no they're not they're just
together
i don't think they're legally married
you know what's interesting at that
level
at that level you if you're steadman
it's like just live in a house
yeah like they got an estate montecito
she's got properties everywhere like
just because nothing's gonna get better
no if you divorce her even if she gives
you a care package yeah it's gonna get
better it's like why you know like i was
with my father this weekend we were in
providence and we drove through newport
yeah and he was just talking to me he
goes you know i don't understand like
why people who get who marry into like
these homes like this why don't they
just keep their mouths shut and just
suck everything up because we were
driving looking at these mansions and my
dad's like money doesn't solve all
problems but it solves most of them well
we're living in a time right now where
people are actually over self-actualized
we can wow okay we came from a time
where see oprah winfrey and steadman
graham had a wedding years uh ago but
never got married right
once their engagement news had been
spread to everyone in the world oprah
and steadman planned to tie the knot in
93. they never chose a specific day
no one else is interesting i don't know
if he's i got to spend time my father 75
years old all weekend with him and it's
interesting he was telling me he was
like you know you you you and and and
your and your friends and your
generation you guys have too much so
that's why you get to press all the time
because you have too much stuff he's
right you have too many things my father
was like i haven't taken a [ __ ] in five
days he goes if i took a [ __ ] today
and i that would be the highlight of my
day he goes i would feel so i would feel
like a million bucks right he goes if i
gave you a million bucks you wouldn't
feel like a million bucks because you'd
look at one of your peers who has two
million bucks he goes so who's rich or
me or you he goes it's me because all i
have to do is [ __ ] and my whole life
will get immensely better so i don't
have anything he goes you have all these
things and you worry about the hole in
your ceiling now you got you know what
car do you want all you have too much he
goes get rid of he was like i want you
to get rid of when we go home get rid of
95 of your clothes i said that all i got
to do is text another girl and have
jasmine see it she'll do it for me right
she'll like the whole thing [ __ ]
fighting yeah i said so so i can see
that one two three but he was like get
rid of your [ __ ] he goes you have your
kids you got your house get
stop over consuming and i guarantee
you'll get happier and i think that
that's the big thing like yeah with the
suicide all that we have too much [ __ ]
well
i you
i believe that there you know when i
when i look at it this is the way that
i've always
uh internalized it i i believe that
different people need very very
different things to be happy right and
the problem with the culture that we've
created is we flattened everyone the
internet's flattened everyone and we've
basically said that everyone's the same
and everyone needs the same things and
that's such a disastrous message to
people because i know people that are
only happy when they are working right
and i know people that are only happy
when they're not working and i know you
know here's the thing knowing somebody
like my dad who's old school whatever
and then again knowing jerry right not
even about the trans stuff jerry but
knowing someone i don't know if you've
ever got a chance to know someone who's
been
institutionalized 20 years or 22 years
in prison right she said the comment the
reason why you have repeat offenders is
not because they're necessarily bad
people she was like i will never repeat
offend
i don't think she will she's like
because i i have a home with you guys i
have a life i i love the kids so i have
something to go home to she's like but
it took me a while to assimilate she
goes the best thing that happened to me
is as soon as i got out of prison cove
it happened and the pandemic and the
world got shut down because it was a
slow assimilation back in society she
said when you're in prison
and every you don't have to do anything
your meals are given to you you're told
what to do you have to go to bed at this
time you have to go wake up at this time
and this this this there's she said you
relax there's something nice she said
about like socialism and communism where
i don't i'm not forced i don't have to
go out and make a million dollars it's
not possible she goes so you're so
relaxed but when you get out into the
real world after staying in that for 20
years you start to get so anxious she
was like that i need this i got to have
that i got to have the right smile i
gotta have the right no she's like when
at she was like at a basic level she
goes the happiest i was when i was in
prison after i got used to it because i
was like i don't have to do anything if
i don't make sense it makes sense it's
also you know we listen we live in a
country where everybody's told they can
be the boss the ceo the star the [ __ ]
athlete right everybody's told they can
be the best everybody's told and listen
there's a lot of that that makes america
like a very great place but then there's
a lot of that where it's like nobody
tells you what to do if that doesn't
work right no but this country does not
focus at all on plan b
right country does not focus every movie
everything made is about following your
dream
conquering the thing yeah but there's
very little thought given to actually
how to construct a life right in this in
this country well that's why for me at
least having kids that's right helps
because i'm like oh literally
pushing my daughter in a swing or taking
my kids to school and having providing a
life for them is like that's it like
what's else do i have to sell at msg all
right sure i'd love to but what let's
break the if you just make everything
smaller i think that's what my dad was
trying to tell me when he's just
constipated and mad he's like just you
you have too much [ __ ] you're trying to
make your life too big make everything
small and you'll be happy i know and
that's how he lives because we'll never
do it no no no not at all
no they're not everyone it's also like
the whole time i've been a little
worried i'm half sold out in burlington
yeah yeah i'm like come on you democrat
[ __ ] guts it's like i'll talk about
bernie sanders here's the deal it's like
you know we all have these experiences
where you whether it's near death or
whatever you know you take a test at a
doctor he's like it's negative whatever
it is and you go how can i get upset
about anything small and then the next
day you're back to yelling and screaming
about traffic
because that's the reality that's what
it is it's just what it is it's the
reality of life i think as you grow i
was just watched on the plane out here i
watched the anthony bourdain documentary
i think what you need to do next time
you look at your father you don't have
[ __ ] enough yeah you go i put you on
the podcast you have a youtube channel
what what's your [ __ ] digital media
strategy yeah you got to flip it on him
yeah you know you have any live dates
yeah you have representation yeah i
would say if i make my life smart i get
less gigs how you gonna [ __ ] embezzle
my money to gamble it on [ __ ] fanduel
you piece of [ __ ]
shout out to fanduel yeah
i like fanduel no moral judgments
everyone's a winner yeah um not my
father where can the people support you
if they if they choose to as a white
south asian non-binary woman anybody can
support me on netflix i have my own uh
netflix he has the netflix special and
i'm gonna have one too maybe mine's out
by now i don't know yeah we we
pre-recorded this because we got to do a
little vacation in august ben's going
ben's going to europe with his wife oh
there you go she's going to europe for
like i mean i mean these people
when they tell you where they go you
just look at them and you go how do you
people how much money do you have they
have more money than me these people
believe it it's
it's disgusting i believe he's gonna i'm
trying i'm gonna make sure he's able to
go for at least 10 days maybe even the
full two weeks with his woman with his
woman i i am just you know
yeah you'll be out by the way anyone who
knows tory burch
please we're gonna do this on every show
have her contact me
fashion designer tori burch please have
her contact me thank you
i don't even know who tory burch is of
course you don't i [ __ ] meet paul
[Laughter]
um
christy comedy.com for everything
patreon.com says christy comedy
especially whether you on netflix that's
really all you need to know are you
going to do
chris what'd you say you want to promote
these dates here oh yeah yeah yeah let's
promote some dates let's promote some
dates but
chicago theater september 30th that's
the best there you go there you go
and san francisco cobbs come out your
homos yeah really nice oh really yeah
we're going to add a show at the
fillmore in philly by the way yeah first
one's sold out um
because he wants to go gallivant europe
so i have to what country's in europe
and slovakia uh my wife had planned a
trip where she's going to see her friend
in slovakia and her brother in germany
oh my god yeah so i'm gonna that'd be
nice he's getting [ __ ] kidnapped i'm
going to allow him yeah to go
so
beautiful she's going to go for two
weeks she might like to be there a week
without you which is her she would with
her friend with her friends i'll go for
like five days yeah you go for a little
bit but you know what i mean the thing
about him what amazes him is how much my
commitment to work all the time right
and you know it's really enriched his
life he's enriched his life to see
someone and to be around someone who
just works constantly and i know he's
got a dumb smirk on his face because he
thinks it's funny but it's not funny
everything i'm doing whether it's
whether i'm in real estate i'm trying to
fix up a house or or i'm working on this
show everything i'm doing is to provide
an example for him right and i hope i
hope he takes the lesson because i won't
be here forever one day i'll be gone and
he'll be
sitting there
in my [ __ ] house probably yeah with
his [ __ ] family yeah and i hope he just
appreciates what's been done for him
he'll be doing the podcast with chelsea
lynn yeah chuck chuck they will move her
fat ass into this chair
so quickly she'll play you in the movie
about your life
chelsea
the tim dillon story
chris thank you so much for coming we
appreciate it bye bye